in each of these cases what I am trying
to find out is a perennial so you can
see here the primary rule down here why
and here's the pro new rule up here feed
up so in the first case I'm after side
in the second case I am after an angle
okay let's have a look at this guy now
every time you look at some question
like this you should have this kind of
framework in the back of your mind it's
sort of like you're putting that
framework on top of here okay so the
first thing you notice is you're after a
side and this is the angle that you've
got how do these two relate to each
other in terms of their position
well 42 degrees is right next to the
side you're after it's right next to it
what's our technical word for that again
adjacent so I'm even going to label this
a DJ for adjacent okay so I know that
I'm going to use a trig ratio with
adjacent inner have a look at the other
side over here that I have the other
information I have access to it's there
in this triangle the hypotenuse so I've
got the adjacent the hypotenuse I think
about my monic and I'm like which ratio
is this it's going to be Jaison
hypotenuse this is going to be cause
isn't it right so I can write an
equation now with causing it that
relates all the information I have in
the question cause of 42 degrees
not because of 40 degrees though also
because of 42 degrees is equal to
adjacent on hypotenuse why 187 do you
care with that I can rearrange a tiny
bit to make Y the subject what will I do
the both sides I should multiply by 87
I'll put Y on the left hand side while
I'm at it and at this point you need to
then reach for your calculator and take
a moment to appreciate the fact that
once upon a time without these things
around you had to look up a book to find
out what this was and then you had to
get a number and you had to multiply
that theme by hand because like I said
these things didn't exist
so back in the old times now just a
really quick note some of you have
siblings who are older who've used your
calculator or maybe you've just lent it
to someone I need you to make sure up in
the talk you can see this icon it's very
very small it's a little square with the
letter D in it a small number of you if
you've let a calculator someone my fine
it has the letter R hi who are you
looking for okay sure
George I anarion now I'd assume yeah did
you get out of his office place thank
you
I would guess you'd go in that way
just be quiet there's exams um Arian
other way okay so have you all but it
can is anyone not have this okay if you
don't have this what you need to do is
go to pretty sure it's shift mode setup
and then what you want to press is three
4° okay all right now for the rest of
you who had their calculator fine you
can go ahead and you can punch this in
and you will get a number out 87 cos 42
so I have 64 points is this the same
time as you 64 point now I'm going to
encourage you especially in an exam but
the way that you get into the right
habit for an exam is to do it now to
write as many decimal places as you can
see they're just just right a ball six
five three five nine nine eight three
that's not where they end but it's where
your calculator stops okay
now the question will usually ask you
for a particular level of accuracy so on
your next line your last line you
provide whatever accuracy was asked of
you what was it what is the question say
one okay
sixty four point seven wonderful okay
now just put your pins in and look up
for a moment before we move on to the
next question what units this is not a
trick question but what units is this
question provided you this is a distance
I just found out what are the units
now the question may actually say to say
in like the top it says it says
centimeters but one of the wonderful
things about trigonometry is an idea is
that it's about position position
relative to other things so in fact if
this was say 87 kilometers
thus would be sixty four point seven
kilometers rather centimeters and it
doesn't matter how big they could be
inches it could be nanometers it could
be anything
trigonometry works regardless of size
that's one of the special things about
it okay so that is the measurement you
have been told it's centimeters for this
particular question but just pay
attention to whatever units your
question supplies yes yes of course
all right now just last in terms of a
question I'll hold your hand with now we
have a look at 2f similar kind of
information but instead of being asked
to find a side we're being asked to find
an angle okay so again you think in the
same terms have a look here's your angle
and then you get provided these two
sides what is their position in relation
to theta
what's the 87 it's right on the other
side there you go so I'm gonna write
opposite 123 it's got to be the
hypotenuse whose opposite the right
angle so I write hypotenuse and now you
think what trig ratio relates the
opposite and hypotenuse it's sewn so I'm
going to write an equation including
sign that relates all of the piece of
information together I'm gonna say sine
theta equals 87 on 123 okay now at this
point you need your calculator again I'm
not going to go this is a easy mistake
to make I'm not gonna say sine of 80 723
because actually I'm trying to get rid
of a side not put one in do you see that
I don't want sine of left hand side I
just want theta so on your calculator
the way you're gonna do that is you're
gonna press I'm gonna clear it you're
going to press shift and then right
above sine you'll see this
label on your just on your calculated it
okay so that's what's going to appear on
your screen and then you're going to put
in 87 on 123 so just like before I'm
going to encourage you to write all the
decimal places that you see okay like so
now again they've asked us to do one
decimal place of accuracy so in this
case it would be forty five point one
decimal place that's a zero is this
enough to make the zero round up and the
answer is no so therefore I'm going to
say well I didn't even say that but
anyway forty five forty five point zero
and this is in degrees okay yeah
question to the nearest ah okay so
because we're finding an angle here
that's right this is a whole different
question
okay it's not normal to provide angles
in decimal points so if you still have
the answer in your display if you don't
have answer in this way put it back if
you still the answer there then you're
gonna look for the button to the left of
all of the trig buttons the degrees
minutes seconds button which looks like
this this one here that's the degrees
with its seconds button or some
calculators even just have degrees
minutes seconds in letters go ahead and
press that okay and then what my
calculator display says is I'll put this
in another color
my calculator display says this 45 11.3
okay do yours match that look okay
alright now this is really important put
your pens down and look up for a second
because you're got to know how to read
this you got now read this we press the
degrees minutes seconds button so what
you've got here are degrees minutes and
seconds
okay so therefore I'd like you to label
on your air to their degrees minutes
seconds okay we went to the nearest
minute how many seconds are there in a
minute there are 60 seconds in a minute
as for time they are 4 angles so how
many seconds would you need to make your
minutes round up mmm this is interesting
isn't it
so does this round up or down it rounds
up to four doesn't it okay and the
reason why is because five is halfway
yeah five is halfway so halfway four
seconds would be thirty so if you had
exactly thirty seconds you would round
that up so that would look something
like this
one minute and 30 point-0 seconds okay
how many seconds is this not very many
just one in a little bit that's clearly
not enough so therefore I can just say
it's 45 degrees and one minute does that
make sense by the way how many minutes
in an hour 60 and just as it is for time
it is for angles there are 60 minutes in
a degree so just like here if this was
45 degrees and 30 minutes that would
round up as well if we wanted to the
nearest degree okay